pour en parler michel fize est avec nous
sur ce plateau michel fize bonjour je
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue auteur
de une insurrection populaire en cours
aux éditions amazon on vient d'entendre
la colère forte de jérôme rodriguez
notamment à cause de cette interdiction
à de manifester par la préfecture de
police de paris
cette colère et face à cette
interdiction qu'est ce qu'elle vous
évoque m'a d'abord elle dure depuis 14
mois
elle a été rejointe par une autre colère
celle de ce que j'appelle mal et gilet
rouge en pensant aux cégétistes en
particulier je crois que ce que jérôme
rodriguez exprime c'est une colère
effectivement très profondes par rapport
à une insatisfaction devant des
revendications qui malgré les milliards
distribués qui ne sont pas d'ailleurs
arrivé dans l'est dans les poches des
intéressées par des revendications qui
n'ont pas été globalement satisfaite
il parle aussi d'une forme de
discrimination c'est à dire qu'il dise
voilà les syndicats eux peuvent défiler
place de la concorde ils ont les
autorisations et nous ont demandé
autorisation on nous interdit de passer
devant l'assemblée nationale de passer
devant le conseil d'état bref de passer
devant des lieux de pouvoir ils parlent
de discrimination vous rejoignez ces
propos alors il est évident que les
syndicats font partie du paysage
politique traditionnelle
donc ils sont avec le gouvernement dans
un jeu de rôle avec des règles qui sont
clairement définis et depuis longtemps
donc on proteste on négocie on aboutit à
effectivement une solution bon sauf que
d'ailleurs dans cette affaire les
syndicats n'obtiennent pas non plus
satisfaction à l'issue des concertations
avec le gouvernement ce qui permet de
dire d'ailleurs qu'il ya quand même
quelque part une jaune isation de la
protestation syndicale qui est aussi
massivement une protestation de la base
syndicale et je crois que les militants
cgt cheminots ou d'autres
organisation ressemble à s'y méprendre
quand même au gilet jaune ordinaire
entre guillemets qu'on a pu connaître
depuis 14 mois justement qui sont ces
derniers irréductibles ça fait soixante
quatre semaines qu'ils sont dans la rue
alors avec des manifestations plus ou
moins nombreuses une participation plus
ou moins nombreuse qui sont ils alors
jérôme ordinaire
on le connaît l'une des figures du
mouvement mais ceux qui viennent tous
les samedis manifester dans les rues
bah je crois qu'on pourrait presque dire
aujourd'hui tout le monde tout le monde
descend dans la rue ou a descendu où
descendra dans la dans la rue il est
évident que nous avions toutes sortes de
catégories professionnelles en novembre
2018 un bon classes populaires et une
partie des classes moyennes
aujourd'hui on a des catégories
évidemment beaucoup plus facilement
identifiables qui ont davantage
d'ailleurs l'habitude de la protestation
dans le cadre du mouvement social
classique je pense aux enseignants aux
personnels soignants aux pompiers aux
policiers même un client qui ont défilé
à certains moments pour compte et c'est
aussi contre leurs conditions de travail
moi je pense que ce qui fédère toutes
ces protestations c'est un mot qui n'est
plus beaucoup employé c'est pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir d'achat de la plupart
des français est en berne un choisi ce
matin le calcul de la baisse des impôts
sur le revenu je crois qu'il faut
préciser deux choses la première c'est
que une partie des catégories les plus
modestes ne sont pas imposables à
l'impôt sur le revenu donc ne bon
bénéficier de rien 2 les catégories
imposé à 11% qui soit dit en passant ne
sont pas des catégories moyennes comme
on l'a dit mais tu es catégories
populaires vont avoir un gain de 300
euros par an en moyenne ce qui veut dire
25 euros par mois et je rajoute pour
ceux qui ont malheureusement l'un
fortune d'être un petit peu au dessus de
1000 euros pour bénéficier évidemment de
cet avantage ceux qui sont à 30% vont
obtenir en moyenne 126 euros par an soit
10 euros par mois
pouvoir d'achat reste sinistré et le
gouvernement ne peut rien faire selon
vous aujourd'hui par rapport à cette
question du pouvoir d'achat pour
finalement calmé un peu cette colère
sociale
le problème est un problème à la fois
politique et économique
la france reste un pays très riche 1
il ya des milliards d'euros qui sont
affectés ailleurs j'ai prendre quelques
chiffres 1 ce que l'on donne
habituellement bon il ya toujours à 60
milliards c'était même un chiffre en
hausse de dividende qui ont été versés
aux actionnaires des entreprises
il ya au bas mot probablement 80
milliards encore d'évasion d'évasion
fiscale là on voit que dans la réforme
des retraites il y aura une baisse des
cotisations pour les très hauts revenus
les cadres ayant de très hauts revenus
ce qui veut dire probablement encore un
déficit de 4 milliards qui va s'ajouter
aux 12 milliards du déséquilibre du
régime de retraite d'ici à 2027
donc l'argent est là l'argent est là
voilà l'argent demande simplement être
mieux réparti pour qu'effectivement
évidemment les augmentations qui
paraissent mirobolantes quand on écoute
les communications politiques ne soient
pas finalement des des petites traîner
sans importance pour conclure quand vous
entendez le chef d'état parlé d'une
société violente
aujourd'hui c'est comment est ce que
vous comprenez ces propos vous savez les
souffrances ont toujours été à l'origine
des colères les colères ont toujours été
à l'origine des dd rébellion donc tant
qu'on éradique pas les raisons de la
colère on ne peut pas espérer apaiser
une situation
merci beaucoup michel fize d'avoir
partager votre avis sur notre plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue auteur
d'une insurrection populaire en cours
aux éditions amazon merci